are you tired of spending hours
searching through documentation
discussion boards and tutorials to find
the right code Snippets especially when
building for the cloud to
sh there was a fun and efficient way to
boost your coding productivity well look
no further because I've got a perfect
solution for you with AI assisted
development you can say goodbye to
syntax headaches and hello to fast and
efficient coding with trustworthy good
quality code suggestions intrigued well
sign up for our developer preview
program to get early access to our AI
powered Google Cloud experience
keep coding and having fun you all